hi e.t welcome to when calls the heart
season eight
played it i am happy to say that that
we will in season eight have a decision
and we'll get to see
elizabeth move on with her romantic life
if season seven ended at a ten we pick
up at an 11.
this season has much higher stakes
it's a very a roller coaster of a season
complicated
that's i really think that's the word
for this year it's complicated
we raise our bar for season eight is
there a
kiss or a big moment of pda
in season eight involving elizabeth
[Laughter]
the first hard-hitting question out of
the gate will this love triangle be
resolved
in season eight yes it will
i'm so happy to say that because i
really think it's about time
love triangles are so exciting to watch
and i think
i'm really proud of the way we've told
this story but they're also
really frustrating and and i have felt
that from the fans that they're like
all right it's enough already let's go i
mean they're enjoying the ride but
they're
like they're so eager to see elizabeth
and baby jack
happy and starting to kind of get to
enjoy that
real courtship oh my gosh cue the
hallelujah sound effect
she definitely makes a decision uh it
takes her most of season eight to get
there
she's being true to uh to her heart when
she makes it
will fans start to zero in on little
clues um in the beginning in the middle
are you guys going to throw us for a
loop yeah the loop thing
the loop thing there are more red
herrings uh
in this season than a zoo is that even a
saying
that's not a saying you think it's going
one way and then all of a sudden it goes
the other way but then it's back to the
other way and
it's all over the place so don't
don't think that you've figured it out
until
until the very end kevin and aaron and i
didn't know
what the final result would be as we
were working on it
it just keeps evolving and and becoming
more and more intense
and at one point you think it's going
one way and then it changes goes the
other way and then it looks like it's
gonna swing back
i hope that they're as on edge as we
were while we were reading the scripts
we will give you a smattering of clues
throughout
um so just everyone put on your
detective outfits and
go to work while you watch what am i
gonna do
sooner or later you're going to have to
decide
i think it's it's been really cool to
watch both suitors um courtship styles
play out we have lucas who's super
direct we have nathan who's a little
more reserved what can you say about how
they're gonna
try to pursue elizabeth in season eight
well i think what at the end of what
happened at the end of season seven for
nathan um he it kind of kicks him into
gear a little bit and he he does start
to get a bit more direct
uh at what he wants and and and what
he's willing to give up to get it
it's unveiled this season why there is
um awkwardness between the two of them
there has been
something that nathan's been holding on
to that um
gets revealed why there's been so much
distance between them
does nathan have heartbreak in his past
yeah but it's not the heartbreak they
think it is it's a different kind of
heartbreak
lucas still has that
maybe more forward confidence whereas
um nathan
it takes him a little bit to kind of
work up work up the courage
but but then he comes out right away
with some
like very strong claims i think he gets
over maybe his
uh his trepidation and comes out full
force
and then lucas is still trying to work
in his way
and then season eight just takes it to
the next level where it's
like people you know people could get
quite hurt depending on the
on the outcome the moments i'm most
interested in are the ones where we get
to see elizabeth kind of
take the reins and and really
lead um lead the guys or guy
there are moments throughout this season
where we get to see elizabeth decide
okay this is now something i'm
comfortable with
and she really has to communicate that
because otherwise how would they know
so getting to see her overcome those
emotional hurdles
uh has just been really interesting and
exciting for me to get to play
i know this is a big question aaron is
there a
kiss or a big moment of pda
in season eight involving elizabeth yes
and yes
[Laughter]
what was your reaction when you read
that in the script i'm i'm so happy that
we've been able to find some closure to
this love triangle and that elizabeth is
going to get to move forward with
this particular man how does the other
suitor
react because we don't want
one of these guys to like leave town or
to you know
i don't know upset when elizabeth
ultimately makes her decision i
we've got we've got the other guy in our
in our best interest as well so what can
you tell me about that
you and me both well i if i have
anything to say about it nobody's
leaving town
okay we're not gonna lose either of
these guys and
uh takes it like a champ
okay good we like that we like a guy who
can take it in stride
i feel like season eight leaves in a
very healthy place
between the three of them with the
mutual understanding and room
for progression in the future in terms
of
building a friendship and a or a very
respectable
dynamic i don't think anybody's really
going to miss chris oh
you guys are always so hard on each
other and we know that you're bff in
real life we saw that fishing trip that
you went on it looked so funny we dig on
a fish you're right i wore my team lucas
chair just for him
as far as the other suitor i think of
course they will be sad i mean that's
just something
you know that's gonna it's gonna take
time to get over
a broken heart the other character is
not going anywhere there's still a
member aaron's kind of made that very
clear
um that they're both members of
yeah of of hope valley when i asked you
this question last year you were team
nathan because
you said you really loved the um parent
connection that they both have in common
i just gotta go with the surge and the
kid right now
you know lucas has to step his game up
he's you know he's
he's against the odds here and he will
he will
a year later i'm gonna ask you the same
question are you team nathan
or team lucas you know i gotta tell you
i've moved
up it's more 50 50 with me now because
lucas brings out
you know as you know he's more worldly
and
i think that's super attractive to
elizabeth yet there's also this real
formula that nathan represents right a
mountie
and so that kind of sets up this family
mounty type of really wonderful hope
valley thing so by the end of the year i
think the audience is really going to be
like
wow is she going to go for this mountie
with a family or she going to go have
some wine in new orleans
[Laughter]
well i know she does make a decision in
season
eight what was your reaction
[Laughter]
was it pure shock just
seriously that there was a decision made
that was that reaction so
in in season eight what is elizabeth's
biggest
challenge what are some of these hurdles
that she's gonna have to overcome
she is so over the moon excited to
bring cooper canfield into her class and
is particularly passionate about about
finding a way to teach
angela canfield who is blind and her
mother is particularly protective of her
there are definitely some challenges
along the way
to hear that there's going to be a
storyline like this where
there's maybe a little bit of friction
and um and conflict
how does she deal with that
not well she gets a little pouty she's
just gonna keep fighting
for this young girl who who has a right
to an education
what do you think i think that mrs
thornton isn't the only talented writer
in town
their relationship is just so special
and fans love watching it
where are they at in season eight are
they just as close
what's going on oh yeah i'd say they're
even stronger
in season eight um what happens at the
beginning
of season eight kind of starts a cycle
for
for nathan to really commit to ali
as a parent ally her character i mean
and jada too as an actress
have grown so much jada really
impressed a lot of people this season um
she had some
really tough scenes and she uh
she killed them she nailed them as like
a father figure
how is nathan handling his you know his
almost
daughter or you know his daughter figure
um growing up
not only is she getting older but you
know she's becoming a woman and he has
no idea
what that's like or you know he can
barely talk to women as it is let alone
raise one
ally kind of experiences a little bit of
romance this season herself
uh that nathan is getting a little
you know he's gotta deal with what
that's like as the father figure
in uh in that scenario how does uncle
nathan
handle the idea of ali starting to like
date or have a crush
i think right now he's pretending like
it doesn't happen but i i think moving
forward with these story lines
there's potential for some very
amusing stories if you think that you
can run my company better than me
buy me out lock stock and barrel
think about it not too long season eight
uh in terms of business and gown
petroleum picks up with lucas in over
his head
it's not going great really what's
what's going wrong what's happening
it gets to a point where lucas needs
going he
he needs him back to help he needs his
help with the with the company
uh so there's a bit of uh that journey
him realizing that he needs
needs at hand 200 and that's just for
the advance
once it's published who knows i'm
getting paid to write
i can't believe it hats off to elizabeth
girl got herself a publishing deal she's
a published author
and a lot of that is thanks to lucas
and his mom kind of you know pushing uh
the agenda forward
are we gonna get to meet lucas's mom
this season or maybe any other family
characters
yes you get to meet lucas's mother and
she's a very sweet lady
there's just some great kind of juicy
stuff in there between
elizabeth and and helen and
in between lucas and and his mother you
learn more about about lucas and his and
his family
and also lucas's philosophy on
love and how
how that philosophy sort of ends up
changing it
if you break him out you're both looking
at 20. i'm a judge
20 would be lenient in my courtroom bill
avery now has become
uh he's wearing an apron a lot he's
in his judge's chamber a lot right he's
also trying to be a mentor to elizabeth
and clara um he has a little bit of
flirtation going on this year there's a
little touch of
mini romance going on we're starting to
open up that part of this character
because it really hasn't happened
for quite a while since aj foster josie
bessette was on the show
it does open up bill to go wow he is a
viable bachelor in town
we need a little tease is this is it
someone we already know somebody you
know and her hair is red
just gonna leave it at that
[Laughter]
happy christmas to all and to all
a good night i can think of at least one
moment where baby jack
interrupts a uh
romantic evening um and so elizabeth has
to
push pause on that to go tend to her
sons little jack and
of course the taylor twins are really
developing their own personalities now
and they're really little people you
can't just kind of
throw them on your hip and expect that
they're going to do whatever you want
them to do
so there are those challenges both
for us just dealing with the twins and
and whether or not they actually feel
like working
maybe one of them wants to work and the
other doesn't and we're i think trying
to incorporate that
a little bit into the little jack
character because that's
what's happening in the taylor twins
lives right now they love talking they
talk all the time
they call me elwynne
and papascal but there have been
really sweet moments